let's talk crypto for a second so let's
pass that debt thing up we can save that
for the next episode i hope you're ready
for the next episode yeah yeah yeah yeah
episode 12. smoke
weed every day
let's talk about crypto this is a
segment we call the crypto corner around
here anyway do you know where crypto's
at right now uh i'm going to say bitcoin
tops 50 i'm sorry do you know where
bitcoin is right now uh it's got to be
and it's 56. the last time i saw it was
like 26. let's check where it's at check
real quick as the filming of the show
bitcoin is at 57 000 dollars here's an
article here's an article that came out
from the street this was uh article
earlier in the week
and look how much crypto has gone up
because this article basically talks
about well there it is bitcoin being 50
grand yeah okay now it's 50. now it's
closer to 60 almost bitcoin's back baby
dude
so
a thousand coins bitcoin
1000 bitcoin yeah so bitcoin surpassed
the 50 000 mark this was last week and
um now it's at 57 and it's inching in on
60 000 it might get there by the end of
the week we'll see so in bitcoin is like
the comeback player of the year you know
you can't count bitcoin out right it's
also like the new kid on the block banks
are like who's this guy he's the
comeback player and he's the rookie of
the year almost yeah um let's take a
look at this guy let's this kid's got
some talent is basically what they're
looking so you know who looked at
bitcoin they said we like this guy we
like this guy uh bank of america
bank
of america
okay okay so when you want to talk legit
they're as legit of an entity as it gets
bank of america okay okay what's that
condescending no it's like when you get
like the cool thing about bitcoin it's
like it's this free thing like this free
market type of thing where it's just
handled by the people and it's all this
but then when you start hearing bank of
america got into it and the big banks
and then there's more government on it
then it's like oh god oh no parents are
here
that's kind of what it feels like trying
to throw a house party in like my
parents just showed up
that's actually a good analogy well yeah
um
see the the flip side to that is you
want some legitimacy to to these big
boys i think it's i mean we're already
legitimized i don't know it's like dude
if you don't trust
i mean it's like come on it's like it's
it's the big one we talk about it for a
reason we talked about a couple episodes
ago about the guy who said crypto was
gonna go to zero what was his name um
uh
i'll tell you his name it was a
big hedge fund guy anyway but then he
argued with kathy wood or kathy's like
you don't know anything you're just like
right right you're a gold hawk
um
[Music]
and he was a guy who made a lot of money
during the 2008 recession big big hedge
fund guy i forget his name john
something um
but you know tesla's in it paypal's in
it um
right there's people that are accepting
bitcoin out there it is it's not widely
accepted exactly when bank of america
shows up dude yeah
that legitimizes things yeah that's big
time legit so i associate like banks
with like there's some sort of
corruption there with their parents yeah
with parents and it's just like oh dude
crypto's like the cool kid at the party
and the parents showed up i do like that
analogy however this you know what
bitcoin does need is think of america's
here
what's going on kids hey what's going on
you got some bitcoin hey cool hey hey
fellow high schoolers fellow high
schoolers how can i get some of this
bitcoin
um all right well whether you think bit
uh bitcoin is the are the cool kids or
bank of america or the uh annoying
parents
this has helped the price go up
okay when bank of america made this
announcement this it crashed over 50 and
now it's approaching 60. so
um it's a legitimate entity no doubt
give me give me this okay it's giving
their cryptocurrencies the seal of
approval that's freaking the story right
there um
it's basically like i feel like it
already had the seal of approval i don't
know it's basically like when um
like who hasn't it's basically like when
mj was like see this kobe kid this kid's
a baller you're like oh damn all right
let's pay attention is that not what
elon musk did when he like was like i'll
take payment for it that's pretty much
he's like you see this bitcoin kid kid's
a baller but then he pulled out because
he had uh well then you know you've got
mental issues well you can also argue
different reasons for that yeah you can
say you know he owns a ton so he
knocks down the price and then buys it
cheaper you know what i'm saying the old
pump and dump the old pump and dump the
old pump and dump anyway here's what
bank of america has to say i know you've
got some serious issues with bank of
america now i'm closing my account right
now
um it says basically with the 2 trillion
market value and 200 million users the
digital asset universe is too large to
ignore per bank of america we believe
that crypto based digital assets could
form an entirely new asset class bitcoin
is important with a market value of
about 1 trillion dollars specifically
but the digital asset ecosystem is so
much more bitcoin was designed as money
but is increasingly viewed as digital
gold i think it's more than just digital
gold um look bottom line is this if
you've got bitcoin you've seen your
wallet increase over the last couple
weeks for sure and bank of america has
helped legitimize this right so if you
don't have bitcoin and you're still on
the fence maybe this is time you just
say
all right maybe i'll throw a couple
bucks towards the bitcoin because bank
of america just kind of stepped in um
look the bottom line is this bitcoin is
no longer just a reddit based uh you
know sort of weird alternative currency
it's out there banks are realizing it
wall street's realizing that fortune 500
companies are watching it it's a real
ass asset class right dollars
um stocks gold silver
crypto yeah it's real out there now
bitcoin for sure
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken